Now I can do anything. I like my friends. I like my podcast. I like my Jason. I like my First of all, though, I would just like to say really fast. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Oh, we'll have to be there, Willard. Happy birthday to you. Oh, my gosh. at birthday to you. Have birthday to you. Oh, we'll have a birthday. Birthday. Well, aren't that. Oh my gosh. Happy birthday to you. And it's on May the 4th.
Be with you. No, no, this is, which is one of my biggest regrets that somebody came up with that. I love it. You can't even. It's first time for me. No, because it just, it's just completely, you know, taking my birthday hostage forever. Not for me. It's, you're lucky you're not born not born on the, on 420, right?
Isn't that the, with all the kids like to smoke their weed on the 420? Huh? 20. Hey man, I've been, I've been looking for ways for you to sound older. Yeah. And I think we just found it, you know,
how about this? Does this sound? Oh, no. Oh, no. I'm, how about this? It's also, but, but, but Jason, for you and me, it's also more importantly, it's Cinco de Quatro. Cinco de Quatro, very big deal. People that know about arrested. And the rest of the development can in Sean.
So thank you. Sean, thank you for following the show. Speaking of Sean, let's take a moment to celebrate Sean's Tony Award nomination. I don't wave it away. It's a big deal. Yeah. Thank you. And very well deserved. Good Lord. That show. Good. Again, just to repeat, anybody going through the Tri-State area, stop in New York City. It's a fun town. And there's a great show. What's the theater? What's the theater? Good night Oscar at the Bolasco Theater. The Bolasco.
Yeah, some people call it Tabasco, but that's just so they can remember it. Jason, do you know what the Tony Awards are short for? Do you know what the actual name of the award is? Anthony's. Close, no. Sean, you know, right? Antoinette.
Antoinette Perry Award. Really? Yeah. God, you know, listen, are you shocked as me at how smart Will every once in a while is, I am. He'd also be shocked to know these actually 67 today. He does have, you do have like an endless well of just knowledge and stuff. I got a lot of time. I got a lot of time on my hands. Literally. Jason, I said to Jason yesterday, I said, hey, do you want to read this thing that I just wrote? And he said, please don't.
Please don't. No, he said, he said, I'm going to send you that script. I said, please don't. He says, what do you mean? I go, I don't, I don't, I don't even read my own texts. Yeah. He's like, well, thank you for your honesty. I just thought, you know, it's just a fun script.
I said, there's nothing fun about reading. I know. Yeah, my parents really screwed me. I just thought, you know, it's just a fun script. I said, there's nothing fun about reading. Did say that. Yeah, my parents really screwed me. Now, I'm watching Sean there, it's his eye. Sean, Sean just had a, we call it, ocular surgery, laser surgery. We don't call it that, but he had a, I can't read, I'm not supposed to read.
He's not supposed to read. And I said, Sean said, Sean turned to the doctor, said, you can't read. And Sean said, boy, do I have some good news for you. He does have a detached ret. So Sean's got a partially detached ret now Jason got a detached personality. So we have hey, hey, oh, um, but, but, uh, but Sean, you're still doing seven shows this week after laser surge. Yeah.
I'm not supposed to read or dart my eye around a lot. And that was the direction from the director, from the doctor said, don't dart your eyes. Wait, it was his note from the director and the doctor. No, and I said to both of you guys, I'm slowly turning into my mother. I'm going to lose my eye. I mean, it's list you've been a knock on wood. No, you mom lost her eye from cancer, you said not from a detached retina. She was two years old.
Yeah, she was two years old. She was two years old when she lost her eye. Oh my god. Yeah, we're still looking for it. So wait, and so I went in and I get vaso vagals. Do you guys get that? Sure. Hey, man, we're trying to keep it clean over here, dude.
What are you? It's when you get nauseous and faint from like, you know, needles or poking at your eyeballs. That's happening to me once. Oh, I get it all the time. That's what I mean once. So you just go out if you get nervous about it. I am like, I have to lay down. I need a fan. I need coolness. I'm going to throw up. I am like, I have to lay down. I need a fan.
I need coolness. I'm going to throw up. I'm going to shoot. We all feel better with a fan around. Let's be honest. Oh, what about doing a show? Do you ever feel it coming on just with nerves for the show? No, no, that's different.
This is all doctor health related stuff. Like if I'm in, I passed out getting contact lenses once. I passed out like, I tried like 10 years ago to get Botox and I passed out. But you're trying to get it fairness. You were trying to get it directly from the cow, right? And it's like, Sean, what I've been amazing is if you passed out going in for Botox and you fell and cut
yourself and then you had to get stitches and then you passed out while trying to get the stitches from the passing of getting. I do, I get it so bad, you guys don't get that. No man. Not just occurred to me, we're doing a full talk show. We do a talk show and right now we're doing the Regis and Kathy Lee pattern beforehand, right? What are you talking about? Well, I used to watch that show and I'm like, how do they come up with this stuff?
Regis just comes in with this coffee, talks about his weekend, and it covers as full national entertainment for 20 minutes. I could talk about 9,000 things for an hour. I don't think people are interested, right? I mean, what are we, what are we doing? Jason, Jason's gonna say is he's not interested in your life. I'm not interested in myself. He's not interested in himself. Let's get to the stage. We are going to get, we are going to get somebody interesting, but I do want to say Jason was so grumpy yesterday. Oh my god. I was impressed. Jason and I played golf the last three days. And then yesterday, we, none of us played particularly well.
Tuesday, we got to play with football great legend, Gareth Bale, who is just an absolute for the Americans. Yeah. I mean, just an absolute. But you had to be like, freaking this guy's a real, I was, I was, God, he's unreal, right? Yeah, you're a little nervous. It was like your plan was Charlie's Theron. I was, yeah, hey man.
Just. How did it come about you guys just play golf with all these people? Right. They just randomly show up. We host a talk show, bro. Yeah. I know, but I'm just saying like, how do you organize that? Well, we met this guy up at some to let golf tournament.
And then that's what happens. Hey, let's play golf. And then we swap numbers. Yeah, he's a good guy. And then that's what happens. Hey, let's play golf. And then we saw numbers. Yeah, he's a good guy. We do. We swap numbers. We go like, Hey, man, we want to play golf with you, Gareth Bailey. So I'm sure at least wanted to play golf.
You would like to play. I'm not answering this. Listen, I'm just pleating. Now I'm now pleading the fifth. Hey, anyway, I was I was a real. So he was a grump. He he spat out of the parking lot into the point that 30 seconds after he left out to come and go, Hey, man, are you okay? Why? Why? He did call because I was getting out of the parking lot into the point that 30 seconds after he left out to come and go, he meant, are you okay?
Why? He did call because I was getting out of the parking lot. I was like, oh, no, maybe I've pissed him off because I don't really say goodbye to anybody. I just had to get out of there before I embarrass myself by like going into some sort of, I played a bad golf round rage. I can't find it. I was proud. It was what happened.
I was putting my stuff in the back of my car and his window was open. And then as he's putting it up and his car is now in drive, he looks over. I'm not exaggerating. He goes like this. I will zip up the window and kill that. And I was like, fuck you. I'll be because you played a bad game. Yeah, I just I play too much to play that badly.
And I just need to be more disciplined and I need to actually really, if I'm gonna, if I'm gonna be upset about not playing well, I need to have a reason to play in other words. I need to start like really training or something. Jay, Jay, I thought about it. I thought about this. And this is not a joke.
We joke about this a lot. We're gonna get to your guess. I feel badly for them, but I just wanna say this, you yesterday, and he does this a lot, did this last two days. No. We're going to, it was that, but I just want to say this. You yesterday, and he does this a lot, did this last two days. We're going to, it was like, hey,
do you want a little bit of food? They got a little snack shack, and I get like a little chicken salad. Maybe you think, and Jason's last two days goes, yeah, just give me a cup of sliced apples. That's all he had. And I'm like, he's starving to death. That's what's going on.
He's literally built can't shake these five or ten pounds. Dude Jason, what I told Jason, if he loses ten pounds, I'm taking him to the fucking hospital. Yeah, you don't need to lose any more weight, Jason. Sean, he ate a cup of sliced apples. That's it. I'm like, that's not enough when you want to. With a cup of nuts on top of those. Don't you get tired during the day from not eating? Yes. I can't wait. I can't wait. You know what I did? Well, there's here's the sickness. I came home. I saw Amanda in the kitchen. She's like, hi, what's wrong? I go, nothing. I'm a disaster.
I'm embarrassed because I'm in a bad mood because of golf. She goes, really? I go, yeah, she goes, we want to talk about it. I said, you don't want any part of me. I'm going to the gym. So I put on my gym clothes and I went and I ran on the elliptical for an hour and then sweated out in the hot box for an hour. So, two hours, I just had to get into a deep sweat to get all the rage out of me. By the way, what you don't hear in there is any nutrition going in. I know. That's what I'm saying.
His mood and blood sugar is plummeting. That's what your body is like screaming at you for backing you up. Both of you to see. There we go. I don't know what the hell you're talking about. Let's get to your guest, huh? Yeah, unless you got some other right. Yes. No, I do. I want to get to the great yet, but did want to want to remind anybody if you're interested in what you're hearing, we have actual actual pictures of us doing this too. Moving pictures there on max, smart
list on the road, the doc that that me,, that, that me, Will and Sean are enjoying, but we're a little biased, we're in it. But if you're interested, it's on Max there, our, our little docu series called on the, yeah. It, you know, May 23rd on Max was the, the day that that's right. Yeah, and they all came out at the same, and you can get all six episodes at the same time. Yeah, if you're a danger, binge away. Yeah, all right, all right, all right. My guest, fellas, listeners, do you like funny people? Sure do.
Talented people, kind people. What if you managed to pack that into one woman? Add two scoops of charm and a cup of conversation skills and what do you get? You get her next guest gang. She's an American actress starring in a new show, which I'm very lucky enough to be a producer on. She's a new mom, an ex-tennis player,
and horseback writer. She's a native California and a proud Sagittarius and the daughter of Lane and Gary. Please welcome pure sunlight wrapped in skin, Miss Kaylee Quokko. Oh, good. Look at her go. Look at her Quokko. Have you ever been called Sunshine wrapped in skin? I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited.
I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited.
I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. Yeah, no, Sean, at your disorder, which I think I have the fainting disorder with needles. That's really? Yes. Yes. Well, then that gets me into my first question. During my deep research, because I'm a crack journalist, you had a horse riding accident where you almost lost your leg. I'm not exposing anything big here. This was already out.
Oh, yeah. How did you deal with that? You're never exposing anything big. So, hey, Will, that sounds like a sexual insult. Now I'm going to let you correct that for a second because it really sounded like I just wanted to say hi, Kayleigh. How are you? I feel like we've only met once before at something that you were hosting. You were backstage and you were like in a complete blackout. It seemed like not, what? No, you had to do a bunch of stuff.
She's probably focused. She's professional. I've never been focused in my life. That is shocking. But it's so I'm so glad to be here. I'm nervous. You guys is like one of the best podcasts in my sister. It's her favorite one.
And she's like, if you mess this up, there's nothing to mess up. There's nothing to mess up. This is the best it gets. We're not going to say it a word in Edgewise. Don't worry about it. Jason's got a big question for you. So settle in and I hope you pack the lunch. So, so, so you're riding a horse. You ride the horse. You're jumping over gates and going around barrels and whatever the fuck you do. And then you get, and then, and then you,
then the horse falls or you fall. The horse falls on you. Lands on the leg is stuck on the leg. Broke, broken the leg. Did you on the leg, broke, broken the leg. Did you ask the horse to get off to the horse, get off immediately? Wait, how long ago was this? This was a while ago. This was, let's see, it was beginning a big bang and we've been probably, I don't know, 12 or 13 years ago. Oh my God, okay, now.
So guys, she almost lost her leg. I once asked her, I once asked her horse to's to get off during a big bag. I see. I'm gonna show it well. So, it's the birthday he's on fire. You really almost lost your leg on this and I was. Well, yeah, no, it was a bad accent. It was a very bad accent. And, yeah, he, I had fallen, the fall didn't hurt me.
He ended up stepping on me. And I remember, I know. And the crazy part is. Sean just faded. Win it. You get that. Sean's down. And he can't do it.
So he's screwed. He looks to get the paddles. So he's dead. Don't fade. Kaley, how old were you when this happened? I was, oh my god, it can't be enough. Early 20s? It was probably 22.
Yeah. Wow. Oh, yeah. Wow. So, so now, but you had to sign something before surgery that gives a doctor permission that once they get in there and they see that maybe we might not be able to save the leg that you won't sue them if you wake up without the leg. Yes. It was a reaction of emergency. It was really serious.
It was serious. So I had to go under. I'd assigned something. Yes, exactly right. And luckily I came out and I was, so but wait, wait, talk to, do you remember, you probably don't remember because you were so under anesthesia,
but when you first woke up, was your first look down to see if the leg was still there? You remember that? Yes, totally. Oh yeah, no, I have a very, yeah. How, what are we talking about? We're talking about it separated from your body, like what? I had a compound fracture.
So for those who don't know it's the bone that comes out of your leg yeah wait wait wait which bone oh that's what I've got my tibia fibula so it's near my ankle and my knee my bones always coming out well this is what they all know is okay it's caught with his bone yeah no. So you had to call it. That's what it's called. Okay. Sorry. I'm going to have to update my first bit taking 100. I'm going to have to update my dating profile. That's what it's called. Wait. I don't know if it works.
You're creating a compound fracture. Yeah. Okay, so wait. Don't come in here. I've got a compound fracture. So wait. Yeah, okay, so wait don't come in here. I've got a cup of So your bone is sticking out of your the top part of your thigh or your bottom No, no, no, no, no, ankle ankle knee. Okay, so there was two. Yeah, and so it just was a horrible horrible horrible break And I had been and you say it didn't hurt? No, it, oh no, it did hurt.
Oh my God, I was gonna say, when I fell, the fall didn't break my, my fall was in the big deal. He stepped on me and I remember a clear as day, because it takes a second when something is up and I was like, did I just fall on a whole thing of leaves? Cause I heard all the cracking. The croncin'. Yeah, so I was like, are there leaves? And it took me like five or 10 seconds
to actually realize it wasn't just 400 leaves, it was my bones. Yeah. So what do you have pins and rods in there? No, I have, you got to do. Do you set off metal detectors? No, I always thought I would, but it never happened. No, no.
Oh my god, what was the recovery like for that? Like just, you know what's crazy? So I was shooting Big Bang. It was on a Friday after work. And so I was supposed to go to work on Monday. They put you behind the bar, right? They gave you like a bar job. Oh my, yes. I'm like, I have to call Chuck Laurie
and tell him right now that I- The great Chuck Laurie. Just, yes, the great Chuck Laurie, but you don't want to make that call. And so they literally didn't think I would like walk for three months. They thought I would not walk for three months. I was walking in a week with a boot. I was back to work in two weeks. It was like miraculous.
Wow. God. Yeah. I mean, I, you know, they always say the worst. And then I, I ended up being okay, but like it, they were very. So wait, you, but you still, it's now, because listen to the story, I'm on pins and needles. So you actually have pins in there for real? Yes, I do. They didn't take those out. They're not planning on taking those out. No, I went back in years later and I was like,
it's just bad to have in there. And they said, honestly, the surgery would be such a pain for you. Like if they're not bothering you, leave it. So I'm, I know. So can you run and jump and do anything? Oh yeah. Do you have fun scars on the bottom of your leg?
Yeah, I do. That's cool. I got the blue scars. I don't have any good scars. You guys don't have any good scars? No. I do. Makes you feel like badass.
I fell off the bunk bed when I was a kid. And I have on the side of my head. Oh, bless you. You're the drunk. Are the bunk bed. I've never met a guy that fell off the top bunk. You know, there's a little bars up there to help. I had a bar online.
Although you just confirmed something that I've lawn suspected. Well, that you're atop. Yeah. I mean, I was gonna say it. And I was like, you know what, I'll say, I do have this scar. Wait, Shawnee, wait, there it is.
Yeah, that's called the belly button. Shawnee, you have lost so much fucking weight. Yeah, I'm not kidding. You lost so much weight. I know, but I'll gain it right away. Will, what did I get you for your blood? Shawnee has set me today, this fucking asshole. He set me for large things of ice cream.
And he said, this is what I used to get fat. To stay in what I used to get fat, happy birthday. what I eat to get fat. Happy birthday. And I'm like, you asshole. Cause now I'm going to eat it. If it's it's calling me if it's in the freezer, what kind of ice cream was it? It's the best chocolate and coffee and vanilla. Yeah. Huh.
The best. I can have creative. It's the best. You either go with the best or you don't. Have you you've gotten into it since then, right? Well, you'll pin it up. This morning, I had a cake last night with the kids. We had ice cream cake because that's my favorite
and yellow cake with chocolate frosting. That's exactly right. Did you use the cake lady? No, no. Mercy made it who is here and she's a great, the cake lady's great, but Mercy makes an incredible cake. And so I will say, because we talked about it earlier, Jason, you going in, I ate the cake, I ate early with the kids
and about 45 minutes after eating two pieces of cake as one of each. Night night. I went, no, another fucker and I went down, I came down into the gym and I were there for an hour. Oh, you did, you have to. Yeah, for you, did you zip into the rubber suit? I hard for an hour. Oh, you did. You have to. Yeah, for you. Did you just zip into the rubber suit? I said, yeah, of course, I always wear the rubber suit as you know.
We'll be right back. Smartness gets support from Helix. Okay. If you've listened to the podcast before, you know that I love me some Helix mattress. Okay? I got the Helix Midnight Lux mattress. And I sleep on it every night, whether I'm here or in Long Island, I'm always on my Helix Midnight Lux.
And if I could like, you know, you see those like shows about those like crazy like billionaires or oil billionaires or whatever and they're like, they ship their cars around the world. If I ever got to be that guy, I'd just ship my mattress. I'd have my Helix midnight lux mattress like in the belly of a 747. That would be the ultimate sign of being full baller in my book. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Lux Collection, the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids that my kids sleep on. Let's talk about the new high-end Helix Elite collection, shall we?
It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions and firmness preferences. Plus, Helix mattresses all come with a 10 or 15 year warranty depending on the model. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listener. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless.
This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With helix, better sleep starts now. Now. Smartness is brought to you in part by Macy's. Father's Day is June 18th, so get ahead of picking the perfect gift for the dads in your life. Whether they love the beach, a great barbecue, indulging in self-care, or somehow trying to combine all of the above as dads do, it's so easy to tailor your gift hunt to dad's tastes with Macy's gift finder. Check out these great ways to shop and more inspo at macy's.com slash gift finder. If you already know dad's signature cologne,ave workout gear, or most lusted after watch,
shop by gift category, or shop by gift lists. Macy's has unique curated gift lists, like for the grill master, for the gamer dad, and for the sports fanatic. Plus, shop Macy's style crew members gift guides, like Thomas and Scott and Brian Moore. They've got gift picks curated just for you and can help spark ideas for even dads that say they don't need anything. By the way, Dad, if you're listening out there, I love you.
And where's my gift? Oh, I get it for him. So head on over to macy's.com slash gift finder to make this father's day an especially memorable one. One more time. That's macy's.com slash gift finder. Hey smart list listener. Amazon five star reviews present.
Feline Euphoria Our first customer review is from Sasha. She writes This robot vacuum is awesome. Never have the cats enjoyed something so much. They want another so they don't have to share. Best cat toy ever. It also cleans well. My allergies thank you, FySars. Thanks for being enthusiastic, Sasha.
Your charisma is overwhelming. That's how you make cleaning not suck, and that's how to make everyday better. Five stars. And now from Amazon Five Star Reviews present? Better than a wooden stake. This review is from a customer that goes by burnt toast. Burnt toast rights. Ever since this three pack of organic garlic was delivered, I have not seen a single vampire. from a customer that goes by burnt toast. Burnt toast rights.
Ever since this three pack of organic garlic was delivered, I have not seen a single vampire. That cannot be a coincidence. Well, update my review of anything changes. Five stars. Wow. Lerious burnt toast. If it doesn't work, at least you got
the beginnings of a good marinara. That's how you make every day better. Five stars. Real ambison, Cusper's real reviews, really. All right, back to the show. Kaylee, you always look so thin. Do you go crazy with junk food at all, ever? Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah? Do you? I mean, you know, I definitely do. Yeah, you know what I also kill? You've got great skin. I've always noticed that about you. Yes, thank you. Yeah, you've got really nice skin. Well, so nice.
Thank you. I know it's really nice to have a work thing this morning and not have to do any hair and makeup whatsoever. It's very exciting. You know, that's on purpose. While we get to look at each other, we're, you know, it's like, I don't want anyone to have to go, oh, you hair and makeup whatsoever. It was very exciting. You know, that's on purpose. You know, while we get to look at each other, we're, you know, it's like, I don't want anyone to have to go, ah, hair and makeup and the whole, it's,
I mean, you guys have to look at me, but other than that, no one has to. Why do you have such good skin, do you stay out of the sun? No, I don't stay out of the sun. I've got quite a skin regimen on my little products, but I'll, but you were very good about putting on some block when you were almost a semi pro tennis star when you were a youngster.
Yes. Wait, what? Let's get it. Yes, she decided. She decided at 16. I could go this way or we could try acting. You were a tennis pro. I did play tennis my whole junior's when I was in,
yeah, that's all I did. And I really thought I was going to be a professional tennis player when I was much younger. Where was's all I did. And I really thought I was gonna be a professional tennis player when I was much younger. Where was that? They didn't hear it. Camerillo. Yeah, in Camerillo.
And then, the Southern California, and then, but I traveled all over the country and I loved it. And then realized, oh my God, you, and I was auditioning and working. And then I got my first show. And I was like, to be a professional tennis player, you'd really just do that. I thought I don't know if I can give myself to both.
So I was like, I'm never going to play again. I put my rackets down at like 16, but I played very competitively for years and years as a young teen and traveled all over and I loved it. Yeah, I loved it. So hard. That takes so much training and so much dedication. I loved it. And you still play a tiny bit?
So I stopped for years. You know, I think when you're competitive in any sport, it's not fun. The fun kind of leaves a little bit. So to play for fun was not something I wanted to do. So over COVID, my girlfriend, who is my oldest friend, who is my doubles partner, when we were really young, she's like, let's start playing again. So we started playing doubles together during COVID and like entered tournaments since it was hysterical and had, I loved it. Because it's socially distant, right? That's
why you could do a during COVID. That's why we'll go back into golf, son of a bitch. So yeah, I heard that you had some rage, but that was interesting story. Oh, real issues. Which time did you hear about? That was interesting story. Oh, real issues. Which time did you hear about? You jump up the guy who did a charge of Tesla? That's one of the greatest stories ever. Now, see, now that's a perfect example of me two years ago versus now.
I exit myself from the situation before I'm accountable for my money. So, wait a minute. I will separate myself from people and just deal with them. I will say that he did approach all of us who were playing with him yesterday and said, one by one, I'm not joking. And he said, hey man, I'm really sorry that I've been kind of grinding and cranky today.
And he went and I heard him say it to the other guys. And I thought, fuck this is a new Jason. That's great. This is my beautiful wife Amanda is teaching me how to be a better man. Kaylee, I have a question about the guys. That's good. Sweet. It's my beautiful wife Amanda is teaching me how to be a better man. Kaley, I have a question about the guys don't fight.
We want to talk to Kaley so bad. I just want to know if she had rage when you played when you. Yes, was your worst moment? Did you ever say you can't be serious? Oh my God.
Are you I broke so many rackets. I had a real bad attitude actually. I to this day you don't want to play Scrabble with me. I am the worst. I am the worst. You don't want to play Scrabble?
Kick your ass and Scrabble. That's exactly how I get to. I lose my shit. I love to win. I don't fuck around. It's not a joke to me. Game night is not, no one wants to let me participate in Game night because I don't make it fun for anybody.
Do you have a game night going right now? Like in this moment. No, I don't. I'm like a gentleman. Like a gentleman. No, I don't. Do you have a game night going right now? Like in this moment. No, I don't know. I don't know. Like in the show. Like in the show. Like in the show. Like in the show.
Sometimes you do game nights. I like games. We love game nights. We are obsessed. But again. When you say we were talking about Tom Palfrey or we know we in Tom Palfrey, we love game nights. Easy on the eyes.
What a guy. I love that. Is that your guy? Is Tom Palfrey? Is Tom Palfrey your guy? Is that your relationship? Tom Palfrey's Pell for your guy? Is that your guy? Tom Fries, my guy. We love game nights.
Okay. I met him because of, it's really, I have to think Jason. They met at the Ozark rap party. If you can believe that. Oh, sweet way. You're the reason I met him. Yes. Yeah.
Now, walk us through the story. Did he know you were coming or did you know he was going to be there? Was there any sort of setup there at all? I don't remember. I knew. So we have the same. I'm sure you've heard this story many times, but we have the same manager. And she, the December, that past December, she had said, I want to set, I want to set
you up with someone that I know. And I said, it was too soon after my last relationship. I was like, no, I'm not ready. She goes noted fine. So in April, I was going to New York to promote flight attendant and my manager, Andrea was like, yeah, so you're sure, yeah, you can edit the applause in later. That would be great. Yep. And we put a little in for Big Bang earlier. Go ahead. Thank you. No, thank you. These are great shows. These are thank you. Please continue.
So I, um, she decided to come with me to New York to just hang out. And she was actually, I'm gonna, my other client is going, I'm gonna see my other client there and she didn't even really say it was Tom, but she said I'm gonna go to Ozark, premier and it's during the week and do you wanna come with me? And it wasn't.
And you were like, what's Ozark? Nobody knows what that is. For 100% I had no, I never heard the show. I didn't wanna go. And so she said, come with me. And I was like, I was like the show. I didn't want to go. And so she said, come with me. And I was like, I was like, okay. And I went with her and got all dolled up. I knew I would meet him, of course,
but it didn't occur to me about anything else. And when I got there, we were a little late. And so everyone was piling into the theater. I didn't have a minute to meet him. And I was actually standing near the waiting the line in the restroom. I was faced away and I overheard, you know, he's got a very sexy voice.
Mr. Tom Palfrey. Yeah, it does. And I overheard him say to our manager, where is this Kayleigh? And I turned around, and it was like, She's right and funny, waiting to take a dump. Yes. And you were like,
That's what I said. Yeah, that's what I said. Yeah, that's what I said to him. And he thought it was really cool that I was so open. No, I saw him and it was like this very strange like the world kind of stopped. Really? Yeah, it was really wild. He gave me this huge bear hug.
And like I said, there were so many people piling and it wasn't a moment to really talk. And so we all just have nice to meet you. Yeah. I mean, he's just real easy with that quick smile, right? He's got a nice, that last smile. Come on. Yeah.
Infectious. And so how many years has that been going on? We've been together for one year. We got pregnant two months in. We have a baby. We were like, boom, boom, boom. We're in sync. Let's go back to my room.
Yeah. You know, we're not 20 anymore. We were like, we doing this or not. So Matilda is a full month. Two months. Five weeks old today. Oh my gosh. Congratulations. Thank you. You had a baby five weeks ago. Can you believe that? No, I can't. I know. And look at you. You don't look like you had a bed like you're just you look great. Tom. Tom actually carried it. Oh, no kidding. No kidding. Yeah, yeah. Oh, that's a good man. They're very progressive. Tom would carry the baby. He is that obsessed. But how do you have energy?
Like aren't you exhausted? Or do you have one of those good babies that sleeps all the time? She, no, she's pretty awesome. Look, I'm not going to lie. We have some very nice help. Yes, I feel even guilty saying it, but we have very nice help, which is why I can like, it's a, I have my relationship is so survived because we have all this help. Yeah, listen, one of them. Oh my god. I mean, yeah, I mean, if he can, if he can, if he got in laws or whatever, I think anything such a big fan of like, it makes you better. Think about this.
In the old days, it used to be people who all lived with their families in the old time. Yeah. And you had family around and family would help out. And you'd have siblings and parents and grandparents and stuff. And it would all end up. And now, at the end of your rope. Yeah, and now it's different. No, exactly.
And it's great to, my mom is here this morning. She was like, so excited. I had something I had to do so she could hang out with a baby for an hour. So it's like, it's great to my mom is here this morning. She was like so excited. I had something I had to do so she could hang out with a baby for an hour. So it's like, it's the best. Now does she mom, does she mom Matilda like you would or do you guys have like a little bit of tension like a don't start trouble?
No, yeah, my mom honestly, my mom is the best. And actually so is Tom's mom. They are like, they come in, they help, they don't overstep it. Do they get along? Do the moms. Oh my God, we're so lucky. They all oddly look like each other too.
And they're they become very close. We're just like really lucky. They are. You're very lucky. We're very lucky. That's great. I know. I know five weeks old.
Do you want more kids? Yeah, we do. Sean, are you moving a couple? Sean, yeah, I'm moving. Do you have any links you moving a couple? Shama yeah, I'm moving a Do you have any links you could send her Yeah, the dark web all right, so let's start with now Big bang is something that was a big bang right with that was a phenomenon
No, I'm 10 12 seasons 12 12 seasons. I mean that's incredible now could you have could you have, could you have gone, kept going, or was it like, this is the right time to end this? You know, I'll be honest with you, and I've talked about this before. We truly are group of actors. We thought we were 100% doing the 13th season. We thought, we'll do a 13th,
that'll be the last one, but, you know, and then, and this story is not new. I'm not giving it a thing. I mean, Jim really did. Jim Parsons really wanted to be done and he was kind of the first person to call it. And we didn't know that was happening. We kind of all thought we were gonna do another season
but we heard it at the beginning of season 12, basically after our second table read, we were told this was gonna be it. And it was actually kind of, I mean, as sad as we all were and a little bit shocked, it was cool because then we had like a whole season to really be in the moment, play.
Yeah, it was cool. We could kind of like slow. We was Jim Show. Was it Jim Show? Originally, yeah, then it kind of became more of an ensemble show. Yeah, he just was, he didn't, he was done. And we were all just, oh my God,
it was so shocking. But then I think over the few weeks, it was like, okay, maybe this is the right thing. And honestly, I mean, for me, I wouldn't have even done, I don't know, flight attendant would have happened. Like the timing was actually amazing. Everything happens for a reason, yeah. A totally, so we were, it was fine.
But that routine of, in front of a wide audience, that is a, do you miss that? I mean, it's so great, right? I loved it. I loved the audience. I thought it would, I loved obviously, I loved the schedule. It was great.
I'm happy now not doing it, but it was such incredible memories. I mean, some of those live shows were some of the best nights of my life for sure. I mean, my dad never missed a deep. He was an audience every week. Every single year. Yeah. He had his own chair at the back of the audience.
Yes. Couldn't sit in it. The angel could not even, he was standing the whole time. And what we do before each show with the little thumbs up. He gave me a thumbs up for curtain call. Every time I came out and the crew, the whole cast would do it too in the crew. Yes, the crew started obviously with my dad. So everyone would do this like thumbs up for my dad. I mean out in the crew. The whole cast would do it too in the crew. Yes, the crew started obviously, my dad.
So everyone would do this like thumbs up for my dad. I mean, he was there, I'm not kidding, every, every shownight for 12 years. My dad came to, none of them, he didn't come to any of them. What are you going to do? Yeah, he didn't come to me. No, he went to Kaley's shows.
You're doing it. Sean, your dad went to every one of Kaley's shows. He was so wonderful. He drove for that. He had a chair. He was so into it. What Kaley, Kaley, how many so wonderful. He drove her dad. He had a chair. So into it. What Kaley, how many episodes did you guys do a big bang? Oh my God. You know what? 100. It was something like that. I actually don't remember the number. 22 times 13. Quick.
We did 20. I'm sure there were some years there were 24 and yeah, 250. Something like that. It was up there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. 100. Oh yeah, yeah. That's so impressive. And it's so, in a, I angel, I'm not just of the schedule, but of like, kind of what Jason was saying, like being able to go and do that every week in front of the audience. That's so, what people don't understand
is how much fun. Yeah, a live audience. He is so free. It's so fun. Now, one, one, we're a kid, and we're at home, we're playing, we's so fun. Now, one more kid at home were playing tennis. Where did the whole thing for acting come from? Was Gary or Lane?
Lane? Am I saying that right? Yeah, Lane. Yes. Yes. Were they into acting at all? Like, who, how did this come about? No, it was concrete.
No, I did a lot of different things when I was younger. You know, my, I would go in auditions, like as I played tennis, I went to these camps that I loved. Like, it was, I had a million things I was doing. So, and it was just, it was smart because nothing ever really got me down. Like, I wasn't like a child actor who was just acting.
Like, I just, it was another thing that I did. And then if that didn't, I had a tennis lesson or I went away for the week at like, they just constantly had me in all these different things and until it got a little bit more serious. And I remember very clearly they sat me down. It was pretty young. I probably was not even eight or nine years old.
And they sat me down there like, you're this is a real job. Like do you wanna keep doing this? And I, there was like not a doubt in my mind. I was like, this is a real job. Like, do you want to keep doing this? And I, there was like, not a doubt in my mind. I was like, this is what I want to do. They're like, are you sure? Yeah. Yeah.
No, sorry, I wanted to be an actor. Oh, yeah, yeah. So keep playing tennis. Keep doing both. Have the second thing. We didn't, they weren't comfortable with me just doing the acting thing. What was the first, what was the first real gig
with the first, first real paying like, Cheerios, something like that? I mean, I did do all those commercials. I was the Barbie girl gig? Were the first real paying like, Cheerios, something like that? I mean, I did do all those commercials. I was the Barbie girl for like two years. I did like a handful of Barbie commercials. I was an other single one. Do you still have them on tape? Oh, yeah, somewhere.
My mom has some sugar. I want to see those. I was the Oscar-Mire. I sang the Oscar-Mire song. I did the EW always. Give us a little. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I don't know what to spell. I wish I were an Oscar-Mire. Wee-Nire we. Exactly. Yes. You sang that in the commercial. Yeah, had to do the whole thing and play against a fake little weiner. Anybody? Anybody? Anybody? I was tossing that up for you. Will I? I know. No, no, no. All right. So then, so then you're you're you're acting along, and your, was there a thought, well, maybe I should go to college too, to have, make sure I have a backup or something. Just go to college.
Hated school, so that was the one thing. I just was not grade school seventh, eighth, and into early, I said, I asked my parents if I could get my GED, and I was very clear on my guys. This is not for me, like, I know my future is not going to be. I don't, I hated school. I just hated it. I didn't even.
I don't need trigonometry. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. It wasn't for me. Even when I had to do set school, like the devastation that I had to, like, leave set to go do school. It just killed my soul. Sure, I think so.
So they let, they were like, I can't believe they listened to me. It's kind of amazing. They let me get my GED. What Gary's very permissive. He was like, go ahead. That's always been the bump on you. They were so cool about it.
I'm such an idiot. Were your parents actors too? No. Oh. No, they were not. My mom was stayed at home with us since the minute we were born. Jay, how do you know their names, Gary?
I'm just doing bits. I get a little bit of research. I know their names and I. I'm just, you know, I'm doing bits, you know, get a little bit of research. I know their names and I'm asking if I know them. It's fun. Okay. Okay. Gary was a realtor. Gary was in residential real estate. Oh, mostly in the Camarillo area. Yes. Yes. Wow. These are guesses. These are guys. He was a, he was a, um, paramedic firefighter actually for a very long time. Wow. Yeah, went into real estate, and my mom, stayed home. I mean, my mom truly drove me all around.
Like, that's all she did was try to get out of the house. Brothers and sisters. My sister, yeah, my sister, three years younger, my sister, three years younger. Did the same thing or no? She did. She loved school, though. She went to high school.
She was like, you know, a little social butterfly, but she's an actor, too. She has an amazing voice. She's incredible. Yeah, she was on mass, butterfly, but she's, she's an actor too. She has an amazing voice. She's incredible. Yeah. She was on mass, no, not mass singer, um, the voice. The voice. Yeah.
Oh, wow. Really? Oh, the voice. Uh-huh. And there are a couple of rounds. Now with, uh, with, with Gary's history and medicine, do you know CPR? What's funny is we just learned CPR because of this baby. Right.
So we had these private CPR sessions, which by the way was terrifying. I don't know if you, they're showing you how to do like the CPR on the baby. That was, I'm like, I'm never gonna remember this, by the way, I'm so traumatized by even doing it on the fake baby. So we did technically learn, but.
I'm not a two, but I think I need to refresh her because I think I may have forgotten maybe, because like you forget one little component, it's useless. You can see Sean and Will, do you guys know CPR? No, I don't, but I can guess. But wait, how to do it? But wait, in a pinch? Yeah, in a pinch I could probably just guess what to do.
You just plug the nose, make out with the person, and then pound on the shot. Yeah, you're right. It's a Saturday, yeah. But wait, I always thought it was so crazy in like movies and TV shows when people, you know, are passed out or whatever dying and people have to do CPR and they're pounding on their chest. How does the actor not like move? Like I'd be like, ow, ow, ow, ow every time.
Yeah, I mean, like you're the worst actor. God. Well, I think the, I remember we had to do CPR in one in a scene in flight and I mean they're pretty padded I don't think we're just soking people in the chat Sean do you want to just you this is like a question hey we got a question from the audience over here For showbiz when you guys are shooting a movie is it real with what are you doing now? It's under that I always wonder that because it looks like what what are you doing? You're pounding. And also when you're breathing when you're breathing into their mouth
in a TV show or movie, and how are you not going, like, you know, how do you like? What about I went down to give you mouth to mouth on Murder Bill. And you just, I thought you were going to let me and then you didn't. And then I was like, wait, you're going to let me.
And you just, I was too embarrassed. Hey, we, you guys, that was so good. Jason, I had to give you, I know I had to put a pill in your mouth. You had to put a pill in my mouth and I had to put a rest in my mouth. And I kept telling you that I hadn't washed my hands. But, but, this is about Kayleigh. I know, this is about Kayleigh. This is about Kayleigh.
So, what did they put pads on? They put pads on. Can you please escort this guy out of the game? I know. This is, they put padding on and then you push on the pad? Yeah. No, huh? No, I didn't know that.
Yeah, and then they'll cut to, you know, his chest and they'll take the pad off. You know, you know, you know, you star wars, you know, they don't shoot that in space, right? Yeah. And the lightsabers are not, they won't really cut you in half. Hey, May the fourth be with you. Good.
And we will be right back. Hey, May the fourth be with you. Good. And we will be right back. Spartanist listener, we get support from Zippercruder. Everybody's got some hidden talents. And, you know, mine is I can do the big loud whistle without using my fingers, so I kind of go like, shhh.
You know, not bad. That was done live in real time. Anyway, the point is this. From hard skills to soft skills, it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful. And if you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open roles, you need zippercrooter.
And right now, you can try it for free at zippercrooter.com-smartless. Zipper Cruder uses powerful technology to find and send you people who skills and experience match your job. If you see someone you're really interested in, Zipper Cruder lets you easily invite them to apply to your job, to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does. Tap into Zipper Cruder's unmatched talent for finding great candidates.
Four out of five employers who post on Zipper Cruder get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cruder for free. Zipper Cruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash SMA RTL ESS. Zipper Cruder. The smartest way to hire. Smartless is supported by state farm. Insurance can be confusing sometimes.
That's why state farm is there for your what ifs because they know the rest of your life is already full of thinking about other things. Like, what if your life was a playlist? Imagine how crazy it would be. Your first song might be a noisy track called Kids. The second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership. Then like 100 more songs called Work, Health, Pets, Cars, Yardwork.
The playlist goes on, and once you put it on repeat and add shuffle mode, things might not sound all that jazzy. That's why the last track you'd want to add to your life's playlist is called Insurance Uncertainties, with lyrics like, what if I'd like to add coverage to my policy? What if I have a question at 3 a.m.? Well, there are some positive notes that can help you keep your life in harmony. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions, because that's just what they do.
So no matter how noisy your life may get, insurance can still be music to your ears. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Call or go to statefarm.com for a quote today. SmartLess is supported by rocket money. OK. I have a bunch of subscriptions over the years that I've accumulated. And I realized recently that some that I thought I didn't have anymore were still ongoing. And embarrassingly enough, I was still paying for them.
Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend around 80 bucks a month on subscriptions. But the actual total is closer to $200 a month. If you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, you need rocket money. Rocket money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Rocket money will quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for anymore,
just hit cancel and Rocket money will cancel it for you. It's that easy. Rocket money also helps you manage all your finances in one place and automatically categorize your expenses. So you can easily track your budget in real time and also get alerted if anything looks off. Over 3 million people have used rocket money, saving the average person up to $720 a year.
So stop throwing your money away. Cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage your expenses the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocketmoney.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Kayleigh, were you prepared for the uber success of Big Bang like all the fame, the notoriety, the money, everything changed and sort of exponentially every year.
Noterite means something bad. Noterite means a big thing. Should be super pilot like a couple times or something. Yes, I was actually the third actress to join Big Bang Theory. Really? Yes. Wow. They did a pie, they did, I believe, two pie.
Old truck had the thinning shears out, huh? 100% yeah. Yeah, yeah. You know who did it? Do you know the people you don't have to say their names, but do you know the people who did it before you, the pilot? I knew one of them. Yeah, I knew one of them.
Awkward, uh, weird. Well, yeah, well, I knew her later. So it was like, it wasn't like she was my friend at the time I'm like, oh, you got a show and then I went and took it But no, I did know her later and she actually ended up guest-arring that she was still friends with everybody was all fine Oh, good. I know so they shot One pilot trashed it to second pilot trashed it and then the third pilot you were in the pilot Yes, they kept rewriting it and revamping it.
I mean, it was totally changed when I joined. Like, it wasn't what it was at all. And so what is it about, like, this is fascinating to me, what is it about that particular show that they kept throwing money at it and redoing it? And what was it that they believed in so much just the concept or, and the actors in it or like, where as opposed to other
shows you should have pilot didn't go they throw it out. Like by right. I think I remember Chuck did a cup. I know he's talked about this before, but he just like really believed in it and the studio believed in Chuck and he kept saying give us another chance give us another chance like I can make I think I'm going to make this work. And you know he's Chuck and he does. So they single hennaley kept sitcoms alive for less.
100% yeah. But he kept saying, I'm gonna get this right, I'm gonna get this right.. You know what's so crazy? I feel like my sort of, I hated him in this word, whatever, this fame or whatever. I was such on a slow uphill climb. I feel like there are actors who gets,
like maybe they do, I don't know, they do some huge film or something that all of a sudden write it overnight fame and they're like, oh my God. I don't really feel like it was like that for me. Like I've kind of, I've been doing this since I was five years old. Not that I was famous back then, but I've always been in the business
and I've always done a million things. And it never affected me that I never felt that moment of, oh my God. I knew in Big Bang's day. Because it was what you did for a living. Yeah, but Big Bang Theory haven't got like 30 million viewers a week, like it was insane. I know, we worked Bang Theory haven't got like 30 million viewers a week. I know. It was insane.
I know. I mean, it was awesome. We were thrilled. Sean and I did when we did that show, The Millers and Special Forces and we were on behind you guys. Oh, me. Behind Big Bang Theory for a year. Yeah.
And you single-handedly like kept us on the air because we had the lead in a Big Bang Theory. We're like, sweet. We could have just air some dial tone if we wanted. But then you can't drop off a lot, right? Then you got the pressure of trying to hold that number. We did drop off. Yeah, then they got, then they moved us and then we were like, oh, we're screwed. But it was a little phenomenon, man.
I don't know. Like, she's just massive. And I know, you know who I know. I know a few people, but I certainly know Johnny a little bit such a nice Of course, oh, he's great. I love him. He's such a nice guy. He's such a nice soul He's like doing his thing. Yeah, really moved to do move to like Tennessee Yeah, that's so great. He's good. I gotta tell him I saw you got talked to you. Yeah, please say hi to inform me
All right, so now what you've done is you've somewhat combined your passion for acting and your passion for tennis, although you're letting Chris Messina do the tennis part, but tell us about this incredible new show called based on a true story produced by Agriette. Do you know that you probably know this, but when I met Mr. Tom Palfrey,
he had this script in his hand. He was reading it like three weeks into dating him. And I go, what do you read? And he goes, I'm reading this based on a true story. I can't do it because I've got some other show. I did know that. Yes. And I read it.
And I was like, give me that. Let me read it. He goes, it's so funny. This is obviously a year ago. Yeah, yeah. And I go, oh my God, this is hilarious. He. He goes, it's so funny. This is obviously a year ago. Yeah, yeah. And I go, oh my god, this is hilarious. He goes, I know it's so funny. It's Jason's doing it and all this stuff is just hilarious.
I still live from Jason's trailer. I can't, yeah. I can't. He'll never read it. He'll never get around to reading it. Well, he was like, you're going to play the plumber. He was going to maybe play in the plumber. After working with him on Ozark, anything and everything I heard about or thought about
you know, and people were talking to me about him. It's like, yeah, what about Tom for this? What about Tom for this? He loves it so much, man. Chances are high that maybe that was something I was aware of, but it was one of many, he probably had a bunch of stuff. But is that crazy that I was like, that's funny. And I went through it.
I said, this is brilliant. Obviously, that was months before I even ever got the call for it. And things were written very differently. The couple had older kids. The story was a little bit different. So once I got the call and I was kind of talking about it with you guys, I was like, I love this so much. But I don't know if I would have teenagers.
Like we started talking and then Craig or showrunner was like, we'll take away the kids. Like they were kind of helping me figure out how this could be. I loved it so much. Plus I loved your crime. I loved tennis. I loved working in LA. I was like, I need all these things.
This is great. So the general concept is that you and Christmasena are married. The great, the great Christmasena. The best. We'll hold for a pause there. The best, the great Chris Messina. The best. We'll hold for a pause there. The best. He plays an X-Tenist star. You play a realtor that is obsessed with True Crime podcast.
You have a plumber come to the house to fix a toilet played by ironically Tom Bateman. Yes, fabulous. Isn't that weird? Yes. And this guy turns out to maybe be a serial killer, and you guys decide, well, we're not going to turn him in if he agrees to do a podcast with us about his serial killer. I got to see him. And we'll keep his name away from the authorities.
No more silly. That's great. There's probably a better way to describe it, but that's the bones of it, right? That sounds great. Wait, when is this on? This is coming. June 8th. June 8th on the peacock. Absolutely. What, this is streaming on the cock?
It's streaming out of the cock. Of course. Yep, yep, yep. Wow. That's what we always say on anything for. Wait, but that sounds really great. I know, it does sound really, really good. It was such a quirky. It was so insane the story. I thought it was so brilliant. I said, I have to be part of this. And then like, after we had signed on, we got everything going.
I came to LA to do some chemistry reads. And Jason wasn't there, but the producers were there. And I was talking to everyone. And I sat them down and like, guys, because they had written it and it was done and ready to go. I was like, guys, what if this character was pregnant? Just a bit more. I was like, what if this character was pregnant?
Just a bit false. Just a bit false. I'm like, now think, think. I'll answer first. Yeah, really think heart, cause this could really be in there. Like, well, I'm like, no, really? And they're looking me and they're like,
what, I'm like, surprise. Oh my God. Oh my God, we were like a month out from shooting, maybe a little longer, but I said, do you think you could write it in? And how many months were you? When we started shooting, I was five months. I mean, we shot three weeks before I gave birth.
Yeah. About up until three weeks before I gave birth. Yeah, so I was five months when we started. So let's say I was like four. Oh my God. And didn't they say, well, well, Kayleigh, we can delay started production. Like have your kid enjoy and you were like, no, no, no, no, no,
I want, right? No, I want to do it now because I also, not only did I want to do the show and I was so ready to do it, I actually not be, and also I wanted to, for them to write in the pregnancy, I actually thought it worked for the show. And once we all talked it out, it actually were, I don't remember it not being about this couple being pregnant.
Plus the way they wrote it in was so brilliant. Like it never focused on the pregnancy. It just was, I was just pregnant. Also, it's the jeopardy too, that you're basically working with the serial killer and you can see this big, huge baby box the whole way through. Yeah, fully pregnant.
That's cool. You were five months pregnant and through till what being eight months pregnant by the time we wrapped? Four weeks before I gave birth, it was my birthday. Yeah, but it was awesome because I got to, I mean, what job I got to eat what I wanted.
I was treated like a frickin' queen. I was the best. I wore what I wanted. I was felt very empowered. And also like, I think this is just so long. Yes, comfy shoes. I've been able to like play my eight.
I've been in this business for so long that I thought it was cool. Like, okay, now people are seeing me like I'm gonna be real about this. And I'm gonna show that this is exactly what I am. And I'm pregnant and it's fine. And I'm working. And I thought it was like a good thing to do.
I don't know, It just felt right. Yeah. I would have killed to play that killer. I want to play. I know he's great. He's really great. Oh my God. He is great. I can't wait to see it. They're all great.
It's really cool, weird show and very funny. Now you're very lucky because it's shot in Los Angeles. You're going to be able to bring Matilda to the set if and when there's a second season. Yes. I've he thought about like how that's all going to kind of play out. I mean, dude, I would a great thing to bring Matilda to the set if and when there's a second season, yes. I've been thought about like how that's all gonna kind of play out. Dude, I would do a second season in a heartbeat. Let's get it done.
Let's get this done today. He was one of the most fun experiences I have ever, I really mean that. And that Christmas scene is just a real joy. We laughed. And that's what's fun, not to, we move on after this. But that is real, I mean, the writing is fantastic, concepts fun and all that stuff,
but the chemistry between you two guys, I don't know, it's just, I do stuff some time when people say, hey boy, how does you guys get such great chemistry? Well, when you have two really nice people, it's pretty simple. Thank you. Chris, Sean Will, don't you guys agree?
Like, chemistry's not a mystery if you're not working with a dickhead. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Chris, Sean Will, don't you guys agree? Like, the campus is not a mystery if you're not working with a dickhead. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly. Chris, just awesome. People are like, well, they had great chemistry. Yeah, because they're normal, nice people. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, it's good. And it's infectious and it works for the characters too because you guys are kind of aweshocksing while working with a serial killer. It's pretty great. No, we had a blast, man. It was awesome. I can't even tell you.
All right. So, about why I just want to say it out loud. It's what's it called again based on a true story, true story, junate streaming on the cock, just so we can say it, just so I can, because neither of you can say it, but I can say it, you know, I can feel it. I can feel it.
Set his calendar. You're ready to do it. We have a viewing part. You're gonna do a viewing. We're doing it. Are you kidding? Are you fucking doing it? What do you, I want to know, I have something. Go ahead, Sean.
Do you have like, do you have any kind of desire to write and to be a writer and to write scripts and like, direct or a little bit? I think I could direct. I think I would be a good director because I like to get in and get out. I don't waste a lot of time. I'm also not every, it was funny working with Macino
who is very likes to prepare and likes to rehearse and watch every playback. I, that is not my jam at all. You're in your arm. Yeah, I like to get in there. Why are we talking about this? Let's just shoot it. And then Chris is like, but we have to,
what are we going to do now? Like he's hysterical. So the two of us together kind of balance those like me with Laura Lenny. Laura was very, very prepared, very sort of always the notes in the squad and the lines always learned. And like it was very admirable. But I just my brain doesn't work.
Me too. A very admirable. I mean, my brain is not working that way either. It's just not for me. I know, but it makes a great partnership. I'm not a playback watcher. As an actor, I can't watch playback. So Tracy, what happens here is that you shoot a scene and then you can go to the monitor,
a little TV next to where you just shot and they'll play it back for you so you can see what you did good, what you did bad, what the technical things are, you need to look out for. Then you go and you shoot it again. And it really was initially, not for the actress, it's for you generally for the director. So the director can watch maybe the producer. See the camera scene. Yeah, see what the camera scene and say,
be like, hey, let's get that again. Maybe there's a bump on the camera move. Maybe the light wasn't right. Maybe the wrong line, whatever. By the way, you know who invented or created the playback? Who's that show? Jerry Lewis. Is that right?
Really? Huh, yeah. Now some actors will not look at playback. And they won't even see the film once it's all done, cut together, and I don't get that. I learned so much about what I did wrong by looking at what I do. Like watching the end product.
Yeah, it's like shoot it and go home and then go to the next job. And it's me too. Otherwise, you just obsess. You obsess about like, what about, you know, I can't do it. I'm the same way. Maybe I should do that with golf. Well, maybe I should care a little bit less. Well, let me just tell you, I was going to say to you, I talked about you at great length
with Josh last night. Oh, boy. This is true. And I did bring him that you're not, you know, Josh. Oh, Josh. Yeah, it's a This is true. And I did bring him that you're not, you know, Josh. Oh, Josh. Yes, I'm a friend of ours and we play golf. Golf or jump. And so Josh, he's a, Kale, he's a friend of ours.
He's a ball, he's a ball fellow. And I keep saying that I want him to start wearing a different wig every day. And I can't even be amazing. Because he keeps his head shaved. And I'm like, if he showed up every day with a different wig, oh my God, I never, that is so fun. So anyway, we were saying, apart from
the fact that Jason, I think you're malnourished and your blood sugar is abnormally low and that that's what makes you cranky all the time in everything you do, not just golf. I think on on top of that, you need to stand over the ball and hit it. Right. You have too many thoughts. And Jason is known as one of the slower golfers in the Los Angeles. I was slow yesterday. I was slow yesterday. And he thinks about way too much. And and Kale, you know, as a actual, you know, competitive
athlete, that sometimes you just have to let it. You're going to go. You gotta go. You gotta go. Yeah. Maybe, maybe Kale needs to be the person to come play with you and walk with you and be your kind of sports psychologist. Yeah, be my whisper. I would be so bad at golf, that sport would make me insane. Like, it would make me insane.
But you could talk him through, you could be like, Jay, speed it up, hit it, hit the ball and hit the ball. What about bowling? Do you guys like to bowl? All right, Kayleigh, this has been great. Yeah, thank you for joining us today. Sorry, unfortunately, somebody decided to capsize the whole thing. We saw a bullshit about bowling.
That's a Tony award-nominated actor. Well, you said Josh is a ball guy, and I'm a ball guy. And then you went to bowling. And I liked to bowl. Antoinette Perry just rolled over and. Kaley, I love you. Thank you guys. You crushed this.
You crushed this. Thank you. This was so great. You got real good chat on your girl. If I was a girl, where is scrunchy in my hair like you do? What do you think of the scrunchy? I always do. This is my bit. I always do with scrunch because old school I always go like, listen guys, the thing is, that I think that I think that what we need to,
I always do my scrunchies. I do it this whole time. I always do my scrunchies there. I love that. I never see the scrunchies very well. I've seen it a bit for under 20 years. Yeah, I was like, guys, I think the problem is, look, if we go over there,
can we, and I see the scrunchies, I think the problem is look if we go over there Can we and I see a phone he's gathering his hair and putting a photo fake scrunchy in his hair Yeah, it's my favorite I love it. I have a big 80's scrunchy. I love it. I love it. Super cute guys are awesome. Thank you All right, thank you. Thank you guys are amazing. Thank you. So have a great rest of the day Kaley thank you. So fun. Have a great rest of the day. Bye, guys. Bye, Kayleigh. Thank you. Bye. Bye. Bye, bye, bye. Bye.
You guys, that's just, she's just, that's a real spirit. You know, she got great vibe on. She said sunshine wrapped in skin, but maybe it's spirit wrapped in skin, huh? And some sunshine. She's one of those personalities, too, that's like a phenomenal actress,
but you can tell is a fun person and doesn't take life serious, like she does her work serious too. Kaylee was, you know, I've asked that. Bubbly Quoco. Sorry. Her name should be Bubbly Quoco. On ice.
Bubbly Quoco. But Kaylee, but she's so great. She was so great on Big Bang theory and so funny and fun. Yeah, just like just like a little great. Yeah, she's had so much life to her. And then you think like, well, maybe that's sort of the character is playing. Nope.
She is that person. She has great energy, great. Yeah, all the time. Yeah, you want to hang out with her immediately. You know, by the way, have you ever exited a plane when the flight attendant, when you're leaving and the flight attendant, or to her over? It is, it is, but go ahead.
Yeah, go ahead. He says. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday sweet sweet willy-our-ninn. Happy birthday. Sweet, sweet, willy-earned, and happy birthday Sweet, sweet, willy-earned, and happy birthday You, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, So cute. That's a good one. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unmbjerf. Smart, less. and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.